well let's go back to the media because
we have this other story i really want
to talk about
the oscars from variety tv ratings
oscars plummet to
record low down 58
compared to last year this is
this is this is there's something bad to
this there is but let's talk about it
they say
per nielsen live same day preliminary
national numbers
an average of 9.85 million viewers tuned
in sunday evening to watch
a more intimate and stripped down
version that's def
that's a 58.3 percent 13.75 million
viewer dropped from last year
13.75 million people
wow now get well go broke
you want it you you want to make this
garbage content and keep pushing your
ins
incessant pandering people aren't going
to want to watch it
the negative is that we have no cohesive
culture we're unified around
we're not all being like we love the
super bowl we love watching the oscars
because it's become
hyper partisan and fractured okay
and good because here's the thing our
our unifying factors before we did have
like the super bowl and some things that
would
draw both sides together and we could
get around there is nothing left that
can do that
and i think that's a good thing for the
short term i think we need to tribalize
and go ahead and say we will not
patronize your woke lecture session you
know
it's a struggle session you know what i
mean it's a chinese communist struggle
session where everyone goes on
and admits their wrongs and wears the
hair shirt and flagellates themselves
who wants to watch that if you're not a
cult member so now
if we opt out and we being the anti-woke
crowd whatever we
determine ourselves to be it's a big
tent you know i'm a big anti-woke tent
guy so
if as long as you're not hassling me
you're welcome in my tent it's
patronize them this is the craziest
thing about you know when i sit down
with
many conservatives because leftists are
worried about getting cancelled
they they will bend the knee to the cult
even if even even anti-woke left
there are many anti-woke leftists like
they're very socialist but they don't
like the cult
they don't want to come on because
they're like i'll get canceled right and
so so i end up talking to conservatives
where on any like policy issue we will
have a debate
but when it comes to the core elements
of what's happening in this country
right now
we agree there's a you know what i think
it is because we talked a lot about
religion with michael knowles we've
talked about this with
many other people it's a judeo-christian
moral framework
versus a might makes right fascistic
anglo-saxon
legal background well so so our
so conservatives and liberals in the
united states share the same
moral framework even if atheist liberals
don't want to accept it right
like the fifth amendment it is rooted
very much so in blackstone's formulation
rooted very much so from the bible the
story of sodom and gomorrah
so when you have liberals who are
atheists still agreeing with the right
to a speedy trial innocent until proven
guilty it's like
this is a moral framework built upon
relig religion
now you may have removed many of those
components or things you didn't like
about it i respect that
but there's still that similar moral
framework the woke operate on a
fascistic moral framework of
might makes right there is no truth but
power
so that's the divide right now so i can
disagree with you know ben shapiro tax
policy
but we agree on morality for the most to
vary
for for the most part i said there's
there's probably a lot of issues we
disagree on
but if it comes from like a libertarian
or a classically liberal american
framework
then we're all basically getting along
be it disagreeing on political issues
and then cracking a beer and having some
pizza or whatever
agreeing to disagree which is no longer
possible with the woke left
all right they they're they don't even
believe it because they believe that
our system our side of the fence is evil
and dangerous
killing the planet killing people and
all these things
so they have you know because it is a
secular religion to them
it is it is inherent on them to fight
and and take us out and so they can't
agree to disagree it's not
possible in their moral framework
anymore because silence is violence
i don't i think most of these i think
maybe to the the priests
of the welcome the woke religion but i
think most people who follow this
are more like blind zealots they don't
actually know or care what the rules are
they just know that it's like they turn
on the tv and everyone's
you know bumping shoulders or elbows
saying the same thing
there are no rules and that's just it so
exactly you can't know what the rules
are but they know they're scared
and so what they're doing is they're
looking around and they're trying to
anticipate
what they shouldn't be doing next so i i
look at
uh you know jimmy kimmel for instance he
goes out on the street in hollywood and
he asks questions of people and they
give him really dumb answers and he
makes fun of him
i know there's a lot of conservatives
who do that to leftists they'll go to
leftist and ask them questions get dumb
answers
and the left does it to write they'll
find right-wingers and get dumb answers
and there are a lot of it's really easy
to do with enough editing
because people are stupid i mean that's
the main problem well because a lot of
people are stupid
for sure people on average are average
very good but if you go out for 10 hours
and you ask you know 100 people you're
going to find
a decent amount of dumb an average
amount to average
and a decent amount of smart then you
edit out all the smart and average
people and get only dumb people and you
make it look
but but i will tell you man i've done so
many interviews with people on the left
and i've talked to many of my friends on
the left and they don't pay attention
i talk to my average friends who are
either like leftists like legit bernie
leftist types
they pay attention they're active i
think they're missing a lot of
information
and then i talk to the average you know
center right or right-wing person
and they're politically active they may
get things wrong but they are
reading more news than the average
person you talk to like the average
liberal
my friends i talk to them and they'll
say things like you know i was talking
to my friend
and we were talking about something with
like you know woke in hollywood or
whatever
and they were like well you gotta admit
you know white people are kind of bad
and i was like what does that mean and
they're like you know and i'm like i
don't
like what does that mean i don't i don't
understand what that means i grew up in
a mixed race area
so i don't know like you're from the
white suburbs what does that mean and
they couldn't give me an answer
it's just something they heard someone
say somewhere so they just repeat it
and that's it it's performative virtue
signaling and they want to do that
because right now
there's only two things that get you one
is wearing the hair shirt and saying
that i'm bad because of my
skin color and the other one is going
ahead and
allowing them to put you in your place
and
they don't want to they don't want to
get caught but they're not informed
as to why this actually is so they can't
to your point make a coherent case for
why they suck
well they just know they suck they just
think if they say that the other person
blindly agrees
right right that's the talking point
that's what the tv told me to say
when someone just goes what does that
mean it reminds me of that moment with
uh with joe rogan and barry weiss you
ever see that
i'm not sure so barry weiss was a new
york times i think she's an opinion
writer
she goes on on joe rogan's show and joe
rogan mentions that he likes tulsi
gabbard
and barry says oh she's such a toady for
assad and then joe just goes
toady what does that mean and barry says
uh
i i don't know she didn't know
so the video goes viral and jimmy dore
makes a video and he's like
look at this and like i think barry's
pretty cool
but that was one of those moments where
you got to know what you're talking
about otherwise you're going to get
called out
so mo some people you know she's
probably she was working the new york
times
right how much you want to bet she's in
the new york times newsroom which we
know is woke
and someone said that and she goes yeah
i know right and then she says someone
goes yeah i know right none of them
actually know what that means
i guess it meant sycophant but she like
couldn't even spell the word i'm not
trying to be mean like you know but if
you go on if you're going to show like
joe rogan
and you say something back it up
otherwise i just been like you know what
you got me i shouldn't even said that
or just you know if you don't know that
that means he's bad
why did you even go there you know
because it's the only lick they had on
tulsi i mean
i i like a lot of the things she says
you know what i mean she's a democrat
and she's an odd kind of democrat which
i can respect
she's a republican now she probably is a
republican but she's on that side of the
fence still
but yeah she was she was wrong about
some things she said about assad he's a
he's a horrible tyrant
and she apologized for him and don't do
that
but like you said know you're doing it
don't just repeat the latest
thing that everyone's saying know what
your criticism is
instead it's like people just blindly
repeat this but
they're reading from the woke prayer
book right all right which is what it is
treat it like a religion and it makes
things so much simpler it's it's
remarkable it's like a lack of
responsibility and it's funny because it
falls into
you know republicans like to say
personal responsibility a lot well i'd
imagine if you believe in personal
responsibility you're probably going to
be responsible for your information
gathering
more so than someone who doesn't yep
someone who thinks the collective will
take care of me
opens at the near time says must be true
new york times said it put the phone
away and i wish
more people on the right or the
individualist side our team
would check their sources because there
is so much garbage and static and
and worthless information gets passed
around by people i like
and i'm like what what it takes ten
seconds click the link
right you know we click even twitter's
telling you do you want to read this
article read the article
before you retweet it easiest way to put
it is that on the right
a failure to collect proper information
tends to be the exception
and on the left it tends to be the rule
right so what the reason i say tends to
is that
i think there are a lot of people on the
right who get it wrong a lot of the time
but is it 45 of the time versus 55
percent of the time they get it right
versus the left which is the other way
around right so i look at a lot of
conservatives i remember watching this
one video where
journalists went down to actually it was
uh there was like a youtuber who goes
down to like a trump event ask people
questions
and you get a lot of like half cocked
answers
where they you know they read more than
just the article but they didn't quite
understand it fully
so they'll say a few things then hit a
roadblock and be like that's the extent
of which i can argue this
and sometimes you look dumb because of
it but you look at like you know my
favorite is the ami horowitz video
where he asks the kids at berkeley about
voter id being racist have you seen that
one
and they're like they're saying the most
insane things ever or actually steven
crowder just did a change my mind on
voter he says you know
not having voter id is racist he sits
down with these people and they can't
even explain their ideas they want to
but they can't
well and they end up making the point
that what they have is the soft bigotry
of low expectations
you know you don't believe that black
people have either agency or
the ability to act as normal american
citizens how racist is that
what i think they do you see i think i
think candace owens said this
that it's it's because black
conservatives act like equals
right it's really interesting when you
have these these college students
i don't i don't want to rehash that more
about the media and and the lack of
understanding
but when you look at these liberals and
they believe the things they just saw on
tv
it's remarkably racist think about this
you get this young woman in this ami
horowitz video and she says these things
about black people which are ridiculous
and untrue
she's saying overtly racist things
disparaging an entire race of people
because cnn said it that's horrifying
yeah that's the the cult in action
basically if your leader says something
and you believe convincingly you believe
it you agree with it and then you repeat
it
and someone challenges you your leader
will be there for you to get in in front
of you and rebuff it for you but in this
case the leader's not there to back you
up
so you hear it on tv you assume that
someone's going to protect you
in defense but there's no logical
pathway right so it's just blind my
faith
i was in san bernardino devotion i was
in san bernardino during a protest there
was trump supporters and there was like
antifa
and i was walking back and forth asking
people like yo what's up what are you
doing trump's reporters all say you know
here for trump you know america first
yeah
i walk across the street and i see a
group of antifa
and i was like hey would any of you
wanna mike check my check
might check they'll start chanting and
then i'm like i stop and then they stop
and i was like i'm just wondering
and the woman goes do not do not answer
any answer any
questions from from journalists
and i'm like what is happening she
basically starts telling them
that journalists will ask them questions
to confuse them
if you got a group of people that will
hear an
external thought and just start
mindlessly chanting
that's a call that's definitely a cult
and the the thing the reason that they
get in trouble when they get singled out
from the flock
is normally they've got those people to
protect them right to either
one person knows another point we've got
a dozen leftists well maybe one person
knows one more additional piece of
information
but collectively none of them or
individually none of them can make that
coherent point
so they have to flock together and i i'd
rather that's again individualist versus
status they're used to being
force-fed information and just ingesting
it and regurgitating it it's amazing
they're happy that way
they don't want to think about they want
to feel it does it make me feel
is this the right thought to feel i just
want to fit in yeah
so i i tweeted oh i tweeted it's like
always ago two plus two equals seven
and then i replied to the tweet i'm just
trying to fit in like that's the joke
when they said two plus two equals five
a bunch of leftists are like actually i
do understand why two plus two could
equal five
and it's like they weren't arguing
language the left was literally arguing
that mathematically
you could argue math it's like no you
can't argue math make the formula work
it's like code
you can't argue with your computer
actually i think the code i put in
should work because this word actually
means the computer is going to be like
error but you can change outcome and
that's what wokeness does
equity is their ability to say okay you
can't do
math but what you did was a math like
operation
therefore we're going to give you credit
for having math
and we're going to pass you to the next
level of math like teaching
and now you don't know anything you
didn't learn anything that's useful
but you got told you did and that's the
whole concept they're doing now and
saying
again another racist concept black
people can't be taught math
the same way as white people well yeah
i'm pretty sure they can
or you're some sort of eugenicist racist
where you believe there are actual
physical differences
and somehow they're not capable i don't
know either of those is a good look for
the left
isn't it weird how democrats have always
been the racist party and they remain
that that way i mean and they project
that's why because that's why they're so
mad about it is because they're scared
when
white liberals walk down the street
they're scared of black people all right
when i walk down the street i'm scared
of black people who are bigger than me
but not most of them you know not
because they're black right
when you're on patriot you're worried
about anybody who's bigger or dangerous
um you know honestly i'm not you know
why i'm not worried about anybody
i've actually been mugged once but for
the same reason when i'm crossing the
street i'm expecting hit by a car
it's just people don't want to hurt
other people for the most part
and the odds are against it and did you
did you know robin d'angelo
who wrote that book white fragility
actually said
which i i think i think it was correct
if i'm wrong that when she goes to
parties full of black people she's
uncomfortable around them jim's the
expert
because i wrote the myth of white
fragility she she said that right yeah
and she
what she believes let me just let me
just say something like
if you're taking your cues from a woman
who admits to you she's a racist
and does it and is uncomfortable on
black people maybe you are following a
racist
i this is the weirdest thing to me i've
been in so many parties in chicago there
have been a bunch of times where me and
my friends like we're going to a party
where it's like on the south side
somewhere
we show up and it's like you know 50
black people and it never crosses our
mind we show up we're like hey we're
like high-fiving people or like dude
where's the cups
it it's it's i can't i can't fathom this
well but her whole ideology revolves
around the fact that she's a racist and
so are you
and so what and that's the entire woke
concept is white liberal guilt says
i feel this way i project it on to you
therefore you do therefore you must
in order to validate the fact that i'm
not just a horrible weak disgusting
person
maybe she's right and these
there's a video where this guy is like
doing a tick tock and he's he's just
like
gleefully saying that he's racist like
he's like hey listen i'm not gonna
actually say it but he says he's racist
and he's like there i said it why is it
so hard just admit it and i'm like
okay you're a racist right i have no
trouble with that
and that but that's the difference
because like you said we treat
black people like people not black
people
they treat them like black people and
they have to have them be black
that's why they had to invert martin
luther king's concept it can't be just
content every character
we have to focus on the color first
otherwise we're not doing
anti-racist thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show
come back to this channel tim cast irl
monday through friday at 8pm where you
can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you